♪
[Ricko] We have to hunt
and kill to survive.
Just like the animals out here.
♪
Most likely the wolves came
along and hamstringed it,
or they're right around here
somewhere.
I'm traveling along
with my snow machine,
looking for a place
to do some wolf snares,
and I come upon a dead,
looks like a calf moose.
From what I can see,
there's some blood.
It might have been bit around
the stomach or the back leg.
And there's a lot
of snow right now,
the moose are real vulnerable.
And, um, I don't think
they could survive much
if they're attacked by a wolf
or a pack of wolves.
So I'm guessing what I'm seeing
right here is a, uh, place
where moose are getting
chewed up by a wolf
and just kind of died.
If I find something like this,
it's unfortunate.
I don't like to see this
happen to a moose,
but it's part of the cycle
of life out here,
but the wolves will be back,
though, for sure.
The wolves are most likely
right around here is my guess,
and they'll be back tonight.
This is part of nature out here.
There were calves, the weakest
ones get killed a lot,
especially in deep snow.
I mean, you look at the snow
out here, if you walk out here,
just right off the trail,
it's this deep.
And then you go into where
the willows are hung,
it's, it's this deep out here.
And that, that calf
really has no chance
against predators out here
and, um, it's unfortunate.
This time of the year,
the, the numbers of moose
get knocked down
and that's what, uh,
predators are doing out here
is hunting moose.
So, I'll keep moving.
I'll just leave it
the way it is
and start looking around
for wolf tracks.
♪
When it comes to food
with us Athabascans,
moose is number one staple
of our diet.
And that's number one staple
of the wolf, too.
You're talking
between six wolves
and 15 wolves in one area.
That's about
the standard size pack.
And when you have
a standard size pack like this,
they kill about a moose a week.
So you do the math on that,
that's a lot of moose they kill
over a set period of time.
When you have a pack of wolves
in your area, or multiple packs,
you lose a lot of moose
population around your area.
So traditionally, we really have
a big part of our culture
as wolfing or predator control.
Especially in the winter when
the moose are most vulnerable.
It's kind of like how humans
have cattle in certain areas.
They have to take care
of their cattle.
With us, moose is our cattle.
So we have to look out
for that animal.
We can't just hunt moose and not
look out for the moose itself.
I got one snare up here.
I'll check it out.
See some fresh tracks going in,
so might be promising.
♪
Tracks going back here.
Put the snare
kind of far back here.
Oh.
Trying to punch through.
A big old trench.
See where they went
through the top here?
♪
Oh.
Holy, I got one.
[Ricko] Holy.
Anaa baasee', Dinaahuto.
Beautiful wolf.
I don't want
to rip it away too hard
because that's frozen down.
That's a good-sized wolf.
♪
Anaa baasee', teekkona.
Teekkona is wolf.
I got to get this out of here.
♪
When I put out wolf sets,
I don't always expect
to catch something.
And once you're able
to have that luck
where the animal come to you,
you have to really show your
appreciation for that animal
by saying thank you.
Because I know how much
it means to my people.
There's only a few of us
out here that can do that.
I feel proud to say
I'm one of them.
Blessed to have that wolf
bring itself to me this way.
I really, truly believe that.
Let's keep moving,
keep checking sets,
and when I'm done,
I'll start skinning.
I got a lot of daylight,
it's warm out.
Anaa baasee'.